we all like to think we are unique
[Music]
so they might be your dna your
fingerprints iris scans or retinal
patterns
we are always leaving digital traces
wherever we go and we can never
be truly offline
there's always the suggestion that
collecting
vast amounts of biometrics is going to
be used for something nefarious but it
can actually
create some incredibly positive
situations so there's a saying
in chinese if you haven't done anything
wrong why would you be scared of ghosts
businesses are typically designed to
make money
and they will not have in general as
much interest in protecting your rights
you are very much the product
fingerprints are something that were
used in very very early chinese pottery
for example
where the potter would leave their
fingerprint in the wet clay
if you watch television and you read all
these forensic fiction
fingerprints solve everything and the
honest truth is that they don't
the fingerprint in isolation has no
value
in telling you who the person is until
you have something to compare it with
[Music]
dna is still the gold standard when we
can identify
the source of the dna whose dna it is
what we're not very good at
understanding is how did it get there so
how did your dna get onto the knife
is it because you use the knife to stab
somebody or is it because
you shook hands with somebody who used
the knife to stop somebody
if you look at the little skin creases
that you have over your knuckles
they're different in every finger
they're different across your two hands
they're different and identical twins
and when infrared light shines on your
veins
it interacts with the deoxygenated blood
and your veins stand out like black tram
lines there is a really strong
chance that the hand and of all the
biometrics that we can see in the hand
may well be that holy grail that we
search for
which is it's unique
so there is a global trend across the
world where
computers uh collect more data and
therefore
uh governments and corporations are
locked in a race where they're trying to
collect
a mass amount of identifying information
gathering data about people who live in
a city or who live in a borough
is now a critical part of a functioning
government if you want to allocate
your resources properly you need the
data
[Music]
[Music]
wouldn't it just be wonderful that you
can put your hand or your finger
on whatever devices it knows exactly who
you are
it knows exactly what your health
statistics are
what the probability is of you catching
cancer because of the gene that you've
got
the options are just limitless
[Music]
netflix which released uh what they
thought was anonymized records of
uh movie watching and their aim was to
try and improve their recommendation
algorithms in other words
if you've watched movies a b and c
you're clearly quite likely to enjoy
watching movie d
unfortunately researchers quickly
realized they were able to
cross-reference these anonymous records
with imdb which is an online movie
ratings service
and once you could identify who someone
is you could work out their sexual
preferences
to some degree of probability
[Music]
you'll be taking in all sorts of data
from local government from your schools
from your workplaces from your companies
where you go your gps data putting it
into one single
school which evaluates how trustworthy
in quotation marks you are like an uber
school where
with a lower credit score you might not
be able to borrow money you might
not be able to travel on a public
transport
[Music]
we're always in a cyber physical space
every place we go to will have some
cyber
element around it there'll be cameras
capturing information
there'll be things that are connecting
to your phone that you may or may not be
aware of
we are always leaving digital traces
wherever we
go and we can never be truly offline
in shenzhen when you're crossing the
road are cctv cameras that use
facial recognition to see if you're jay
walking or not
and then identifying who that citizen is
and then sometimes you'll be displayed
on a big billboard on the other side of
the road being a sort of name and shame
action what happens in china and in
other countries
is a cautionary lesson for all of us but
unless you have proper regulation
the gathering of your data is a real
danger to our human rights
[Music]
the landscape is continually changing
who would have thought
10 years ago we'd have had all this
collection that we have
now who would have thought about the
ways that data can be used
and abused so regulation is always
chasing
where we are with the current technology
if they provide you with pages and pages
of
terms and conditions well that's
transparent so we can all read those
however do we really have the time and
the knowledge to read all of those
no so are we really in a situation where
it's not transparent
but it's apparent to us are we aware
biometric data is
very personal it's your data because
it's about you they're your fingerprints
or it's your dna
once it's given away it is incredibly
hard if not impossible to take it back
i have a real conflict between
how much of my information i want to
share
and how much information i want to have
available to me
when i go to a crime scene i want to be
able to find the pieces of dna i want to
be able to find the fingerprints
i want to be able to get every single
bit of information i can
to make sure that justice is served but
of course here i am
sitting in in the middle of that crime
scene not wanting to give mine that old
saying
well if you have nothing to hide you
have nothing to fear that kind of
approach doesn't value our privacy
if the government said we're going to
put a camera
in every single bedroom in the country
that would film
what happens in your bedroom but we
assure you we will only turn it on
if we think there's suspicion i think
most members of the public
would say i don't have anything to hide
but this is my bedroom this is private
in reality
there are so many ways to gather data
about you nowadays and it can give
as detailed information in some ways
about you as if you were having a camera
in your bedroom
large size data sets or databases are
incredibly useful but the critical thing
is that they are correctly used so
that's going to be a very very big
question that we need to resolve as this
digital world really starts to
accelerate around us
thanks for watching if you enjoyed that
be sure to check out these videos next
and if you haven't already
hit the subscribe button and click the
bell to get a notification each time we
upload a new video